okay
so guys i am in my uber right now and
i'm having a conversation with my uber
driver about the amber herd and johnny
depp case
so
um she's a woman
what do you whose side are you on
team johnny team johnny
um what do you think of the outcome did
you hear that before i was just making
the video in this uber uh no the first i
heard was when you were reading
you know
there's a lot of manipulation in the
system right now i think you have a lot
of valid points
and
i'm glad that
he was able to prove
his innocence um
like you say it took away his career and
it was tried in the
the court of the media instead of
being done legally and
i think you have a valid point that a
lot of people manipulate the system
yeah well i think did you know women get
three or men get three times the same
sentencing as women do for the same
crime
yeah i believe that statistic uh the
system is very broken
and um
it's gonna take a lot
to
fix it but things like this are gonna be
what does it because you're drawing
attention to it
you know so um
yeah
do you so okay this is what i was
thinking like i don't know if you heard
me talking earlier i'm sure you did but
like was just thinking this had to has
to have happened to so many guys
because like this man had the money to
you know hire his own media team and
lawyers and he couldn't even do anything
about it yeah it's crazy
[Music]
do you remember when um like that was
super prevalent the me too era oh
absolutely and and you know there's a
lot of valid points in that too so um
like you say it has to be done legally
it can't be this public opinion
everybody's coming out with the sand a
sound bite to get an emotional response
instead of logically
looking at the facts
and evaluating the situation for what it
is
do you okay so
with the director that got like caught
back then like do you remember he was he
was propositioning sex for roles
do you remember couch yeah it was a joke
running joke for years yeah but like my
thought even because i think that's
that's clearly wrong right absolutely
but my question is why are the girls
agreeing to it like i i'm in media
there's nothing a dude could say to me
to make me sleep with him for like a job
or a role you know but there's no
accountability on the like woman other
problem in society that
sex is seen as a commodity
rather than a sacred act
until we can learn how to love ourselves
who we are
instead of what we can get
then we're gonna continue to go around
in the same circle
yeah it seems like society's kind of
breaking down the family to be honest
like like people aren't really getting
married like they used to or staying
married and you you keep hearing about
more and more like toxic situations like
this
well yeah there's a lot of generational
trauma and you know there's a lot to be
said about the dalai lama suggests that
we should teach all eight-year-olds to
meditate
because i don't know about you when i
when like the me too stuff was going on
and when i hear things like people say
like men are trash remember the problem
like i take it personally because i have
five brothers
so i'm just like i don't know they're
good men
yeah so yes it's it's it's it's your
core values yeah
you know that that
and we value this
you know we're after the next shiny
thing
instead of what really matters i think
is at the base of it
[Music]
the
do you so do you consider yourself a
feminist
you know um
i always worked
at a job where i got the same pay
as all my male counterparts
because just a federal service
wasn't
no i could never accept being paid class
for the same job so i guess so but i
don't
make it blatant
okay it's just it's interesting because
when i ask a lot of girls if they're
feminists they're kind of reluctant to
say yes a lot of the time or like they
don't say like a screaming yes and i i
feel like it's because of stuff like
this like the me too
that a lot of us as girls like while we
may want to you know be paid equal but
like we're not with the like man-hating
parts of feminism right right right
where they take it so far it's almost
like a war on men yeah it becomes
another cult you know and
i think that division we need to focus
on what we have in common more than
what divides us yeah
that's that's really like i think
florida people are kind of
like a lot of people agree with more of
the stuff i put out in florida
it seems like a lot more of a
conservative like state
i'm not saying you're conservative but
someone's like oh i am yeah i definitely
am okay
you should you should check out
my my page it's just pearly things
itself all right yeah we do we advocate
for men on this channel a lot so we'll
talk about with just like
laws that are unfair like
fun the intro is not fun interesting one
i learned this week there was on the
case in ohio
where
uh the woman gave up a kid for adoption
even though the dad like wanted to take
the kid and like they didn't even get
his consent so it's just like
stuff like that that are just unfair
again yeah you need
because um you know we all have rights
and we all want to be seen
and it shouldn't matter
what your sex is
yeah
no i i definitely agree well thank you
for doing this video this is like an
impromptu i was just like i need to talk
to someone about this
my uber driver is here
but your face isn't in it or anything so
don't don't worry about the word
okay guys um
this is this is breaking from the uber
okay um also my friend jess is live on
the channel right now so
um go watch that when you're done with
all the johnny heard amber depp or
johnny depp amber heard stuff okay bye